bravo les filles vous avez bien
travaillé dans cette exploitation
familiale on élève pas que des chèvres
on les cajole
à la tête du domaine 7 jours sur 7 André
il a repris avec son épouse le domaine
de ses beaux-parents en 2014
actuellement j'ai 200 chèvres en
lactation longue et saisonnière
avec une production
de à peu près entre 500 58 jours et ces
demoiselles de rassalpine dispose d'un
parc de détente en plein air et de trois
services par jour une bonne alimentation
produite à 75% sur place céréales
principalement en sec donc maïs
avoine tourteau de colza
légumineuses pour
du trèfle
l'usé en déshydratée et foin de prairie
naturelle à la frontière avec le
Loir-et-Cher André Muriel et leurs
employés produisent et affines deux
fromages d'appellation le sel sur Cher
et le Valençay la vente se fait en
direct les habitués s'y pressent
je peux le dire et c'est ce que je veux
donc des fromages blancs et des secs
avec de la sauce la famille veut rester
discrète même si elle a la culture des
concours et des médailles il y a
longtemps que qu'on participe au
concours de sainte-more de Touraine
puisque ça ça regroupe pas mal
d'appellations et cette année
on a eu le Graal le Graal pour cette
pyramide qui vient de décrocher la
Chèvre d'Or tout simplement le meilleur
fromage AOP de France une fierté pour
toute la famille
Chèvre d'Or ici
on a toujours eu médaille d'or mais on
n'a jamais passé le stade au-dessus mais
là avec les enfants qui ont eu le chèvre
d'or pour moi c'est
ne mordez pas trop parce que sinon je
vais ça va pas le faire le trophée trône
RA très prochainement au-dessus de la
vitrine avec probablement quelques
larmes de joie